welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and multiverse of madness is about to
answer a lot of the burning questions
that we had after the chaotically
magical season of wand division last
year but since it has been a whole last
year since we've last gotten a nice
relaxing vacation to west view new
jersey which is a very popular
destination i thought it would be fun if
we reminisced on some of those
unresolved mysteries that one division
left dangling for us after a season
finale full of absolutely insane moments
and revelations because there are a good
number of plot threads that are likely
to be picked up and addressed in wanda
maximoff's next major mcu adventure in
multiverse of madness so let's just dive
into it my nerd babies because you got
some stuff to talk about but before i do
make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick up the latest
obsession shirt inspired by moon knight
tomb of the moon god it's not going to
be around forever so pick that up today
so you can have one just in time for
moon knight to show up in the midnight
suns because you know it's coming you
know the midnight suns are coming so
make sure you have your moon night shirt
today alright so one of wanda vision's
greatest cliffhangers is of course the
series final moments of wanda maximoff
making some tea and reading a light
novel written by one of the darkest most
vile forces in the known universe and no
i'm not talking about the deathly
hallows i'm talking about the darkhold a
different dh this is of course after
wanda would steal the dark hole from the
possession of agatha harkness before
locking the dark mad witch in a prison
of her own mind but of course before
wanda does agatha harkness warns her of
the dangers of her own power combined
with the dark dunes that dwell with the
damned of the darkhold you have no idea
what you've unleashed
you're gonna need me
if i do
i know where to find you wait so at some
point in multiverse or madness we are
definitely going to find out exactly
what wanda has been doing during her
time in seclusion and just how much
she's learned from the dark hole to
cause her to become the ultra powered up
illuminati headquarters destroying force
to be reckoned with that we see in the
trailers because much like agatha
mentions in one division wanda's biggest
problem wasn't power because wanda was
like juiced up one of the most powerful
beings in the universe no it was her
severe ignorance towards even the basic
elements of the magical world power
isn't your problem it's knowledge and it
is quite clear that wanda for sure took
those words to heart and has been
feeding her mind with the dangerous
influence of this dark demonic
dictionary and since it seems heavily
implied that agatha harkness became too
corrupted by the darkhold's influence to
be left alive by the witches of salem
wanda's super creepy vibe in the
multiverse of madness trailers makes so
much sense and very much implies in my
eyes that we will be seeing much more of
how the darkhold is driving the scarlet
witch into a world of madness because my
nerd babies if you turn your nerd baby
bibles to the book of carnage chapter
eight page six you will find that when
you use the dark hole you just don't use
the dark hole the darkhold uses you and
speaking of agatha harkness with her own
disney plush show on the way with house
of harpness we will likely be seeing
what our favorite nosy neighbor has been
up to as the citizens of west view all
collectively heal from their shared
televised trauma and possibly start to
see the measures by which agatha has
been trying to break herself free from
wanda spell of being trapped in the body
of this nosy neighbor agnes that isn't
actually who agatha really is with the
title of the agatha centric show house
of harpness possibly referring to a
metaphorical house built in agatha
harkness's head with the entire show
being set within agatha's own mind
palace as she navigates her way through
the memories of her past much like she
forced wanda to relive her own tragic
memories in the show and sort of how we
see mark and steve journey through a
mind palace of their own making in
episode 5 of moon knight but in the case
of the sequel to doctor strange we also
do know that agatha harkness shares a
mission extremely similar to that of the
pissed off evil baron mordo which is
taking magical power from people that
they both deem undeserving so in the
case of multiverse of madness we could
see this original recipe mordo being the
one who helps agatha break through
wanda's spell so they can both team up
together to steal everyone's magic
because mordo only started doing this
agatha's been doing this for centuries
but another important thing to note with
agatha is what she was saying when she
was first reading the darkhold to wanda
in the one division finale mainly about
the prophecy of the scarlet witch and
how the scarlet witch is destined to
destroy the world with a power that
surpasses that of the current and even
former sorcerer supreme wong and steven
strange well if there's anything that
these multiverse of madness trailers
have been doing well it's been
establishing that this version of wanda
maximoff is going to be the strongest
that we have ever seen her to date with
her being able to apparently go head to
head with what looks like to be a
variant of captain marvel a hero that
marvel studios head kevin feige has
stated on numerous occasions to be the
strongest character in the marvel
cinematic universe and i said strongest
i didn't say most powerful i said
strongest though technically she would
be
yeah
but while wanda's power levels are
without question what is with plenty of
question is just how she will end up
becoming this harbinger of the world's
destruction like agatha harkness says
because for the multiverse of madness
trailers we do get a sense that a dark
hole structure will come into play at
some point that will likely tie into
this dark ominous prophecy along with
these creatures from recent tv spots
that many people on the internet have
said resemble the dark author of the
darkhold c'thon so i fully expect
whatever apocalypse scenario that agatha
harkness was warning wanda had just
unleashed in one division to manifest
itself at this darkhold temple in the
film like that is straight up the act
iii temple in my opinion and of course
we gotta talk about wanda's entire
family cause because it's the whole
reason for the season first of all where
the hell did white vision go because
like dude learn something new at his
local library and then check the [ __ ]
out well an important thing to note here
before he did is that white vision is
now technically a chaos being like wanda
as of the very end of wand division
episode 8 when human ass floss tyler
hayward uses wanda maximoff's chaos
magic to power up sword's new updated
version of vision so while this vision
has indeed been restored with the
original memories of the vision there is
a very significant chance in my opinion
coursing within his vibranium body will
begin to affect his behavior much like
the chaos magic that courses within
wanda has been slowly affecting her
mental stability and amplifying her
existing depression over time ever since
she had the chaos magic within her
amplified by the mind stone chaos magic
is a highly emotional source of energy
and guys our friends at the epic hero
shop have some of the coolest shirts and
merch when the thor love and thunder
trailer dropped they asked us for some
help with zooming in and enhancing and
were able to recreate the trucker hat
that thor wears during his training
montage and you can get one for your own
training montage and they even have a
new spider-man noise home shirt with
peter parker's face and who the hell is
this it's both very clever and the only
one of its kind and a very cool shirt to
wear to the theater to see multiverse or
madness would be the wanda variant of
the unusual couple shirt it's an
augmented reality shirt so you can use
your phone to unlock a video layer of
the shirt order soon so you'll have the
shirt in time for the premiere and
they've got all kinds of great marvel dc
and star wars inspired gear at
epichiroshop.com including the shirt
that i'm wearing right now look at boba
fett looking real cool badass
[ __ ] sign up for their
newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about merge
drops and be your own hero today at
epicuroshop.com so now that vision is
flying around with a new chaos magic
power source combined with swords new
messed up programming matrix swimming
around in his high-tech noggin this new
vision powered by the darkness of chaos
magic has a pretty high chance of being
super messed up and potentially a pawn
to be used for dark entities lurking in
the shadows like your k-thons your
multi-armed defender stranges that i
believe to have been corrupted by chaos
magic or hell even the dread dormammu
himself who we all know wants nothing
more to make his way back to mcu earth
using avatars like casilius but there's
also the mystery of billy and tommy who
we know for sure will be playing
prominent roles in this movie as they
are the main reason why wanda maximoff
has been burning the midnight oil and
the midday tea filling her mind with the
devil's fan fiction written in the
darkhold and given that billy and tommy
were revealed to be merely infinity
stone energy given form by the scarlet
witch's mastery of both chaos magic and
the mind stone energy living inside of
her after the mind stone exploded in
wakanda wanda maximov has likely been
using her deep connection to the
darkness of chaos magic too as sorcerer
supreme wong puts it scour the dark
borders between known and unknown
universes for the purposes of finding a
multiverse where billy and tommy
actually exist possibly with plans to
steal them from another wanda maximal
variant so she can have them all for
herself that would be pretty freaking
diabolical however since we do have this
shot of wanda maximoff confronting and
consoling a variant of herself from the
trailers i also believe that there is a
possibility that wanda maximoff has been
going from reality to reality absorbing
the powers of her scarlet witch variants
to fully aid her in being able to
rewrite reality on a multiversal level
not just a universe multiversal level
for the purposes of her children
existing in every single possible
reality so no other scarlet witch
variant would ever have to suffer again
because wanda has been doing nothing but
suffering since she was a child so i can
totally see wanda maxima of doing this
and hey it beats kidnapping kids right
yondu
you're dead i'm sorry but of course the
biggest wtf moment of one division has
got to be the whole ralph boner thing
right i mean come on this was supposed
to be fox x-men quicksilver am i right i
mean that's some random struggling actor
named boner boner
so i would highly expect the appearance
of evan peters peter maximoff proper in
doctor strange 2 to explain to audiences
everywhere that the ralph boner twisted
wand division wasn't made to torture us
and be me but instead it was the first
introduction to the concept of
multiverse variants to the general
public which is actually something i
directly asked loki showrunner michael
waldron when marvel studios allowed me
to interview him last year before loki
debut which was the coolest thing that
ever happened to me i love michael
waldron a lot but those are just some of
the biggest mysteries wandavision has
left us ever since the year 2021. what
do you guys think do you guys think that
all these mysteries will be addressed in
multiverse of madness is it still the
ship with theseus or are there other
mysteries that you think i missed let us
know in the comment section below but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mrtainment on twitter if you want to see
me tweet some really weird [ __ ] but
really interesting theories but more
importantly you can follow new rock
shows wherever we are on social media
when you do on youtube make sure you hit
the notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video and hey again hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can find our
latest tomb of the moon god latest
obsession shirt and also all of our
other amazing merch options there we
have a lot of cool nerd stuff so head
over to new rockstarsmerch.com today and
of course discord is always where we
like to continue our nerdy conversations
so if you are 18 years old and older
please head to the description box below
to just find our discord link and join
the conversation there but again thank
you guys so much for watching you can
follow me at mastertainment on twitter
and i'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you